tandis que je trouve sur la mise à jour
ne viendrait sous la toise et le voit il
ya quelques trucs sympathiques comme à
chaque fois aller au lit aux attentes
j'oubliais tradition aujourd'hui ce sera
la culotte samouraï
voilà de retour dans cette famille c'est
vrai qu'ils avaient la rénovation
graphique maintenant tout est
extrêmement jolie et on va tout de suite
se diriger vers la première nouveauté
mais regardez qu'est ce donc que ça un
petit labyrinthe dans lequel va trouver
quelque chose de très pratique vraiment
même dans la vie de tous les jours
d'ailleurs pour ceux qui aiment bricoler
on peut le dire juste là il y ait pas
d'en moyenne [ __ ] de scie circulaire
qui fait un max de son compte twitter un
ennemi au nom tous les psychopathes qui
vient cette vidéo sont déçus car l'autre
nouveauté vous allez voir allez on va
dans bâtiment et on va découvrir des
choses extraordinaires
oh c'est nouveau ça le bureau du
proviseur mon pote proviseur pro
profession at elle a carrément fait le
cliché du proviseur sexy dans un manga
non l'abus total attend ya pas de
problème pour tuer des gens si c'est
elle qui nous couvre guerrière et voilà
les clubs sur la nouveauté de cette
nouvelle version de l'un des régulateurs
et maintenant des clubs par exemple le
club deux cuisines bonjour les filles
j'aimerais cuisine avec vous par contre
j'espère que les coquillettes fromage
je peux quand même vous pas qu'elle
allait à mon avis n ya un leader et qui
parlait pour rejoindre le club mais où
est le leader je crois que tu peux pas
encore rejoint le club de cuisine c'est
trop hype pour nous tu vois tu retiens
tout visage de petite conne là je vous
exterminer la gueule l'argent votre club
auparavant le petit rtp1 tu vas au didot
au plomb dans la tête alors je peux
venir
allez je vais étudier les filles je me
propose en tant que nouvelle présidente
de ce club qui ne répondent pas qu'on
sent occulte club au cerceau vous savez
qu'on avait découvert la dernière fois
maintenant 6 2 c'est devenu un club
cette école part en couilles tu as lu je
me bats lui parler regardez les plonger
dans ce bouquin quoi à quel moment s'est
autorisé dans une école ça au regard des
allèles brassard c'est la cheffe du du
club
elle fait peur vraiment est fait plus
peur que yann david chane je veux les
infos sur ton club vous aider vous à la
recherche de supernatural et des
phénomènes paranormaux sorcières
vampires fantômes des mois etc et ceux
qui voyagent dans le temps sont
bienvenus ici tu sais qu'ils rejoignent
notre club développe rom résistance aux
choses terrifiantes et affreuse ou
succomberont à cause d'eux c'est drôle
on s'amuse à aller je rejoins un club ça
a vraiment l'air extrêmement amusant
beaucoup d'humour dans ce club tu
rejoins que le veau culte les élèves
mettront plus de temps à autres marques
et noms mal et ce avec des élèves de
tests que
le monde n'est pas un endroit je vais
quitter comme je vois là club activity
c'est quoi ça la lune n'est pas bien
positionnés revient entre 5 heures et 5
heures 30 boîtes à temps je vous revenir
je vois ce qui se passe
ok on est bon il est entre 5 et 5,30 et
alors on va essayer d'appeler à des
monts bon quoi c'est quoi ça il me la
place des mots à ils n'ont pas réussi à
marquer d'accord mais c'est abusé ils
sont bizarres
manquerait plus que sympa il passe
devant la porte à son lait c'est terminé
pour moi
six avocats des mots alors avant de
passer sous mon club il ya une petite
tout était dans une salle mais je sais
pas où est la salle on va essayer de
trouver ensemble comment il sait pas ça
non c'est une somme il ya plein de table
la pierre à feu du monde quoi oui c'est
la regarderait comment c'est glauque ya
un pc avec une fille qui nous parle et
s'il ya quelqu'un au sétois qui cette
femme bordel qu'est devenu aussi le
provoquer ces notions des reichel en
fait est-ce que même tu sais qui je suis
je sais qui tu es ok je sais ce que tu
es bon ça va mais perdent on n'autorise
pas d'aller à l'école ponctué active
il ya des raisons de tolérer la présence
de cette école et je n'en ai aucune tu
es une créature vulgaire à kingsey smic
net se servir une cause ce système aux
décisions j'espère mais une riche qu'un
d'entre vous amuse toi ton qu'il peut si
jamais nos chemins se croisent tu vas
passer un mauvais moment
ok à mon avis ces notions d'ericsson
comme elle qui veut buts et toutes ses
rivales pour avoir saint pie
sauf qu'elle n'arrivera jamais à nous
défoncer parce qu'on va tout de suite
rejoindre des arts martiaux
oui parce que mon travail c'est aussi de
faire d'escrimeur irl si vous avez eu
peur n'hésitez pas à lâcher un gros
pouce vert à vous abonner est là où
j'essaie de combler le vide le temps de
rejoindre le club des arts martiaux
question affaires ou est ce club s'il
vous plaît où est le clone librairie
c'est nouveau ça dit dont un aurait put
un grosse librairie un club d'arts
martiaux nous y sommes
on la quête alors voilà c'est ça qui me
plaît un thébaux t oh purée je te
complimente vraiment je complimente
avant de faire une prise de choix dans
la gueule le patron du club et là
bonjour patron allègement le club
fantastique je vais maintenant partie du
club des arts martiaux aller et je peux
changer au hachis d'ail hachée passer
devant et le bouleau sont aux noms n'ont
toujours pas tu n'y vas pas puisque je
me rechange voilà tu c'est bon tu peux
changer tu peux changer c'est une blague
c'est une blague vas-y jarret jack
stéphanie c'est pas grave alors comment
est ce qu'on peut se [ __ ] là
j'aimerais faire l'activité du club s'il
te plaît excellent appliquer comment
sont ok es tu me pète pas le nez se
plaire voilà c'est ça l'activité c'est
tout ah non mais faisait qu'on puisse
déjouer des activités on va s'entraîner
pendant trois ans jusqu'à pernaut chou
et devenir vraiment très fort
alors oui qu'est ce qui se passe pour
toi tout s'est tellement traîné comme
une carpe et un crâne rasé on va tous
les prendre leur pied en photo ok tu vas
faire la question à faire c'est pas du
tarp wahlburgers question affaires
bâtard au lèche week-end un [ __ ]
génial allemande mur vive le club d un
patient regardez l'udac ou jusqu'à 100 m
le loser ça dégage in situ affaires
question au nom non pardon pardon pardon
elle est partie elle aussi bien vous en
dernier sous la tour de notre vie